at the start of the movie an ordinary
looking cobbler uses a sewing machine to
fix a shoe of his Rich customer however
when he tries on the shoes he shockingly
turns into the rich man and starts
driving around the city in a luxurious
car then he starts mending another pair
of shoes but when he doesn't realize is
that they belong to his old customer who
has already died lo and behold he tries
on the shoes and this time transforms
into the dead man with this attire he
scares off a bunch of gangsters and
causes their car to collide against an
oncoming truck surprisingly he is left
unharmed by the deadly crash now with
this newfound ability he can explore and
live any life that he desires to
following this the movie flashes back to
the 19th century in the Lower East Side
of Manhattan a bunch of concerned
entrepreneurs have held a meeting to
discuss the skyrocketing rents around
the neighborhood which has already
caused several businesses to go bankrupt
with no options left they ask a local
cobbler pinches simpkin for help who
supposedly has some mysterious abilities
the men then hand over with a pair of
shoes belonging to the landlord and
request him to do his magic although
hesitant at first pinchess agrees and
then he starts repairing the worn out
shoes on his sewing machine which
appears to be very peculiar the movie
then cuts to the present day and we are
introduced to the protagonist Max simkin
a fourth generation descendant of
pinches he is the same guy from the
opening scene who is yet to realize his
magical powers just like his ancestors
he has inherited the cobbler shop and
works very hard for a living Max lives
with his old and sick mom Sarah in a
tiny apartment and it is revealed that
his father left them years ago as for
his acquaintances he's close to a barber
named Jimmy who has a shop right beside
Max's one day as Max is going about with
his day a lady enters his shop she
introduces herself as Carmen a social
worker who works for the welfare of the
tenants in the Lower East Side due to
the continuous encroachment by luxury
real estate owners some people are
forcefully being evicted hence Carmen is
going door to door with a petition so
that the government will intervene and
stop the rich owners from harassing the
poor tenants although Max doesn't care
much about the cause he finds Carmen
cute and signs the petition for her oh
the lengths to which a simpkin will go
the following day a rude guy named
Ludlow enters the shop and demands Max
polish his shoes to which the latter
agrees once done he is impressed by
Max's work and leaves another pair of
shoes to have them fixed after Ludlow
leaves Max immediately gets to work and
starts mending the shoes however to his
Misfortune his electric sewing machine
experiences a malfunction rendering it
useless he tries calling for a repairman
but everyone seems to be busy that week
hence left with no other options Max
heads down to the basement and starts
searching for a sewing machine that is
still operable he eventually finds one
the same one his ancestor pinchess used
at the start of the movie wasting no
time Max operates the old machine and
starts mending the shoes after he
finishes up he heads upstairs and
innocently tries on the expensive shoes
and as soon as he does so he
surprisingly transforms into Ludlow
taken aback Max quickly takes off the
shoes and with this he he reverts back
to his original form he then tries on
another pair of shoes from his shop but
nothing happens with those after
thinking about it for a while it finally
Dawns on him that the transformation
takes place only when he mends shoes
with his vintage ancestral sewing
machine to test his theory he closes up
shop and begins to repair some old shoes
using the Vintage sewing machine then he
tries them on one by one and transforms
into a completely different person every
time now Max can finally change his
boring life around and become anybody he
wants to be in one instance he
transforms into a Chinese man and walks
around Chinatown in another instance he
dines at a lavish restaurant and leaves
without paying by changing his
appearance he also changes into a rich
man and drives his luxury car around the
city in this way Max's monotonous life
suddenly becomes colorful after he
discovers his ancestors magical machine
the next morning while he's working at a
shop a beautiful lady named Taryn
arrives and asks him to fix her
boyfriend Emiliano's shoes oh boy Max is
instantly captivated by her beauty so he
thinks of a plan using the magical
machine he changes into Emiliano who
turns out to be a handsome young man and
goes to a local bar there he becomes the
center of Attraction of all the girls
present inside this motivates Max and he
heads straight to Emiliano's apartment
where he finds Taryn taking a shower
surprisingly she becomes excited and
calls him to take a shower with her Max
immediately accepts but when he realizes
that taking off his shoes will revert
him back to his original form he makes
various excuses and flees with days
passing by Max also starts growing an
infatuation for Carmen and he stalks her
using various disguises that night he
happily approaches his mother and asks
her if she wants to be somebody Sarah
replies no but expresses her desire to
meet her husband just once hearing this
Max gets an idea in his mind no Max no
the following night he arranges a
romantic dinner for Sarah and also buys
a lovely dress no Max no then as she is
busy getting ready he transforms into
his father and approaches her as
expected the innocent old woman is
delighted to reunite with her husband
after years she doesn't ask much about
his whereabouts and simply enjoys the
moment the two then have dinner talk
about their early days and also dance
Max in the form of his father then takes
Sarah to bed and Remains by her side
until she falls asleep thank God Max
unfortunately the next morning Max finds
out that she has passed away peacefully
in no time a lot of people gather at the
place to commemorate Sarah's life but
Max is too distracted for it he blames
himself internally for his mother's loss
seeing him upset Jimmy tries to cheer
him up but Max simply leaves without
speaking a word despite the tragedy he
returns to work the next day the first
customer is Ludlow who has come to
retrieve his shoes however since he has
lost his receipt Max refuses to hand in
the shoes claiming that it's hard to
find a pair among thousands expectedly
this angers The Arrogant customer and he
threatens Max to find the shoes by the
evening or else there will be trouble
never get between a guy named Ludlow and
his shoes after Ludlow leaves Max
immediately decides to take revenge for
the humiliation he just suffered so he
covertly follows Ludlow by changing
appearances various times along the way
he finds out that Ludlow is a gangster
who makes a living by threatening and
beating up others shortly after Ludlow
reaches his apartment but swiftly leaves
with his guys for some business taking
this as the perfect opportunity Max
disguises himself as Ludlow and enters
his apartment to steal whatever
valuables he can get his hands on there
he encounters ludlow's angry girlfriend
who is about to move out of the place
because of the constant abuse she has
suffered over the years once he is alone
Max starts searching the place and finds
a secret suitcase which is loaded with
weapons he picks up a fancy taser gun
and attempts to play with it but ends up
tasing himself to unconsciousness a few
hours later he wakes up and prepares to
leave but unfortunately Ludlow arrives
at the same time the gangster is shocked
to see his doppelganger and immediately
starts strangling him well ludlow's into
some kinky stuff but luckily Max has
kept the taser gun which he uses to
knock the real lovelo out when he wakes
up he finds himself tied up to a chair
soon Max approaches him as a transgender
man and starts threatening for some
valuables left with no options Ludlow
leads him to a secret vault which
contains some expensive watches just
then a few guys arrive outside the door
who are revealed to be ludlow's gang
members at first Max gets scared that he
will get caught but when Ludlow spills
the beans that the men are here to
escort him to collect 50 Grand from
someone he becomes confident he then
disguises himself as Ludlow approaches
the gang members and sets off with them
leaving the original Ludlow unattended
along the way one of the gang members
mentions that he has a surprise for his
boss AKA Ludlow and takes him to a
secret garage there some of his other
gang members have imprisoned and beaten
up a guy named Patrick who is supposedly
trying to steal from them seeing all the
blood and violence Max becomes
disoriented and heads to the bathroom
after recuperating for a while he comes
out and orders his men to release the
culprit claiming that everyone deserves
a second chance as expected the goons
are surprised as they are not used to
seeing their boss pardoning anyone but
when Max insists they agree to let
Patrick go following this Max and the
thugs continue their journey and reach a
large Mansion which belongs to a real
estate owner named Elaine greenewalt
without further Ado she hands over an
envelope containing 50 G's to Max I.E
Ludlow and orders him to finish off the
target the latter pretends to know the
work and leaves confidently with his men
unfortunately when Max returns back to
the apartment and his transgender
disguise Ludlow is waiting for him with
a gun the gangster then tries to choke
him to death but Max cleverly takes off
one of his shoes and reverts back to his
original form startling Ludlow taking
advantage of the opportunity Max tries
to escape but ends up inadvertently
stabbing Ludlow in the neck with his
pointed stilettos as the gangster slowly
passes away a terrified Max flees from
the scene however the very next morning
he heads straight to the police station
to turn himself in after taking all his
statements some policemen arrive at the
apartment with Max but lo and behold
there is not a single sign of the murder
ludlow's body the blood marks the money
and even the guns have all disappeared
Max drives his best to convince everyone
that he is telling the truth but due to
the lack of evidence the officers leave
after a while Max returns to his shop
and gets taken aback to see the money
and guns lying on the table fed up with
everything happening around him as of
late he grabs everything and prepares to
leave but just then Jimmy stops him he
expresses his concern that Max has been
acting really weird since his mother's
demise and he is always absent from his
shop however the latter pays no heed to
the speech and continues on his way in
the next scene Max heads to Elaine's
Mansion disguised as the transgender man
he makes up a story that Ludlow is
incapable of executing the mission so he
has sent him to return the money however
Elaine clearly sees through his lies and
orders her men to knock him out that
night when Max wakes up he is being
transported by two men inside the car
they appear to be talking about burning
up an apartment they also discuss the
different ways to execute the
transgender man and hearing this Max
quickly tries on a pair of shoes and
transforms himself into a dead man
seeing him the men get terrified and end
up crashing the vehicle allowing Max to
flee the next morning when he reaches
his shop he notices a flyer that Carmen
left for him earlier on going through it
he realizes that the tenant she's
fighting for Solomon is the same guy
Elaine's men were talking about worried
he quickly heads to Carmen's office to
discuss the situation through her he
learns that Elaine is a wealthy
businesswoman who wants to demolish an
apartment and build a department store
there so far she has managed to buy all
of the tenants there but Solomon is
unwilling to move later the two head to
Solomon's place and tell him everything
about how Elaine and her men are
planning to kill him but surprisingly
the old man still refuses to go away
claiming that he has a lot of memories
in the apartment hearing this Carmen
becomes sad but just then an idea
crosses Max's mind the next morning he
meets a land disguised as Solomon and
proposes a deal he will leave the place
in exchange for 100 grand and a ticket
to Chicago where he can meet his
daughter Elaine immediately agrees and
leaves the place to make the necessary
arrangements that evening two of her men
Jeffrey and Brian arrive at Solomon's
apartment to hand over the money as
everyone is busy Max cleverly hides
their shoes use and sets his plan in
motion first he disguises himself as
Jeffrey and calls Elaine mentioning that
Solomon has left with Brian shortly
after when the real Jeffrey returns to
Solomon's apartment Max disguises
himself as Brian and knocks him out
elsewhere the real Solomon is with the
real Brian but as soon as they reach the
airport the police apprehend Brian after
finding a weapon on him the following
day Carmen bumps into Elaine and tells
her that she just visited Solomon
hearing this the cunning woman is in
disbelief as Jeffrey had informed her
that Solomon had left for Chicago the
night before she rushes to the apartment
to see for herself and finds the man
still there in reality it is just max
disguised as Solomon enraged Elaine
threatens to kill Solomon and his
daughter if he doesn't leave right away
but to her Misfortune a group of
reporters barge inside the room it turns
out that the whole thing was just an
elaborate setup to frame Elaine for her
wrongdoings that evening after
successfully imprisoning Elaine Max and
Carmen catch up and agree to go on a
date on the weekend the same night Max
disguises himself as Ludlow for one last
time to approach his girlfriend he hands
her over some of ludlow's watches so
that she can sell them and to earn a
decent amount unfortunately when she is
returning Patrick and his men apprehend
him and start driving away but before
they can get very far an oncoming truck
crashes into them when Max wakes up he
finds himself in Jimmy's Barbershop the
latter reveals that he pulled him out of
the car wreckage and brought him here
confused Max inquires as to why he
always looks after him and in response
Jimmy takes off his shoes and changes
into his real self in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that Jimmy is none
other than Max's Father Abraham as Max
watches in disbelief The Old Man reveals
that he had to hide himself to keep his
family safe as some really bad people
were after him then he leads Max to a
secret compartment where hundreds of
luxurious shoes are being capped each
and every one of them was worn by a
noble person from a different decade
Abraham then reveals that disguising
oneself is in the simpkin family's blood
and now it's Max's turn to lead that
life then the father-son duo emerged
from the back entrance where a lavish
car and a driver are waiting for them
the movie ends as they talk about the
magical sewing machine and how it came
into existence subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching